ELLEN SPERTUS: Thank you
for coming here today
to hear Jessica Stern of IGLHRC.
Jessica Stern is the
executive director
of the International Gay and
Lesbian Human Rights Commission
and specializes in gender,
sexuality, and human rights
globally.
She was the first researcher
on LGBT rights at Human Rights
Watch and a Ralph Bunche Fellow
at Amnesty International,
where she conducted fact-finding
investigations and advocacy
in relation to Iran, Kyrgyzstan,
South Africa, and the United
Arab Emirates.
Prior to working
internationally,
she campaigned extensively for
social and economic justice
in the United States
for the Center
for Constitutional Rights, the
National Gay and Lesbian Task
Force, the Urban
Justice Center, and is
a co-founding collective member
of Bluestockings bookstore.
A past board member of
Queers for Economic Justice,
she currently serves on the
board of the International Bar
Association's committee on
LGBT rights and the law.
Educated at the London
School of Economics,
she's taught graduate
and law classes
at Columbia University, the
City University of New York,
and Universidad de los Andes.
There's paragraphs
more I could read
about her many accomplishments,
but instead I'd
like to say a few words
about my experiences.
I've been following
IGLHRC, as it's called,
for about two decades.
I remember when there was
the change in government
in South Africa, that they
played a role in getting
LGBT rights enshrined into
the constitution, which
is one of the best in the world.
I also remember that
back when they started,
it was because no other
organization was looking
at LGBT rights internationally.
There'd been a movement to try
to get Amnesty International
to include homosexuals among
the prisoners of conscience,
but they didn't.
Back then in 1990,
gay rights was not
considered human rights.
And that has changed,
Amnesty International,
Human Rights Watch, IGLHRC
also pioneered work on asylum
for people escaping prejudice
against GLBTs and people
with AIDS, another group
they've worked to help.
And now that standard,
that's accepted.
When I visited the IGLHRC
offices about 20 years ago,
I remember seeing
their database and how
surprised I was that
for gender, they
had male, female, and other.
And nowadays, that's
something that we pretty much
take for granted.
It's offered on Facebook
and some Google projects.
But back then, it wasn't.
It's because of
pioneers like IGLHRC
that so many other organizations
are doing similar work.
Unfortunately, there's
still a lot left to do.
As William Gibson said,
"The future is already here.
It's just not very
evenly distributed."
So there have been
tremendous advances
in GLBT rights in
the United States
and some other
countries, although more
remains to be done.
But we set our clocks
back an hour this weekend.
Uganda recently set
it back 100 years.
So if you've ever wished you
could have helped the pioneers
before, who worked
hard, who were brave,
who showed themselves
like Alan Turing,
before it was safe to do
so, you can help such people
through groups like IGLHRC.
OK, I'll turn things
over to our speaker.
JESSICA STERN: I'm Jessica,
and I thank Ellen Spertus very
much for organizing this
today, and I thank all of you
for working through
lunch to talk
about LGBT rights
and social justice.
Ellen gave the acronym
of my organization
because that is how
we call ourselves,
but we actually have
a very long name.
It's the International Gay
and Lesbian Human Rights
Commission,
I-G-L-H-R-C for short.
And it doesn't sound good in any
language anywhere in the world,
but I'm going to say
IGLHRC a lot today.
I'm probably going to speak
in acronyms a fair amount.
The one I'll use most
frequently is LGBT.
Do people know what LGBT means?
Yes, OK.
In case anyone's
unfamiliar, it's
Lesbian, Gay, Bisexual,
and Transgender.
And we're talking about
LGBT rights globally today,
so I really want to
underscore that "LGBT"
is a placeholder for much more
nuanced, much more complicated
ways of describing
ourselves, whether it's
how I would present myself to
someone in a bar in the Castro
or how I would describe myself
if I were speaking in Spanish.
So LGBT is going to be
the jargon you here today.
And perhaps during the
question and answer,
we can talk about other terms
that you think are relevant.
So the title of my
talk is "Post-Sochi,
Where LGBT Rights are Getting
the Gold and Getting Prison
Terms."
And I propose that we talk
about four key issues today.
So the first is what's been
happening internationally
for LGBT rights, and
I'm going to focus
on three of the biggest
stories of late as
kind of case studies.
So we're going to talk about
Russia, India, and Uganda.
The second thing I
want to talk about
is, what meaning and effect
do these laws actually have?
Are they just laws on the books,
or are there consequences?
At that point, I think you
might feel really depressed,
so the next topic will
be reasons for hope.
And then the
fourth, final, and I
think most important piece
is global solidarity.
What works, what doesn't?
How does that sound?
All right?
OK, great.
Thank you.
So starting with what's
happening today for LGBT rights
internationally, I
would argue to you
that over the last six
months, LGBT rights
have assumed an unheralded
prominence in global affairs.
And I'm going to
start with Russia.
So in June of 2013, in the
name of children's rights,
Russian President Vladimir
Putin passed a law
that takes aim at
anyone, it claims,
quote, "promoting nontraditional
sexual relations."
And I always love
terms like that, right,
because they're so
broadly defined.
And we know that the code is,
in many ways, homosexuality.
In this particular
context, we know this
because we know what
arguments have been used.
But actually what's
really being criminalized
is any sexuality that's
not considered acceptable
at a current moment.
Under this law what
I would probably
describe as life-saving
information about LGBT
rights and public
health was equated
with pornography and
child sexual abuse.
Any individual or legal
entity, quote unquote,
"distributing" information about
these nontraditional sexual
relations can be punished.
And the fines range from
$3,100 for an individual
to $31,000 for a legal entity.
And I have to tell
you that I don't
know a single nonprofit
anywhere in the world,
whether in Russia or
elsewhere, that has
$31,000 to spare because
they've been doing LGBT rights
education.
And I definitely don't know
a single activist anywhere
that has $3,000 to spare.
And given that
we're at Google, I
think it's important to say
that the fines range in size,
but the steeper fines
are for information
that's distributed online.
So information that
anybody can get to
is some of the
information that is
seen as the most threatening,
the most criminal.
And I want to mention that prior
to President Putin's signature,
the lower chamber of the federal
assembly, the State Duma,
passed this bill unanimously.
But there's good news.
This terrible bill was
enacted, but outrage
erupted internationally.
Let me run through some
of the examples of this.
First, you probably read
about it in the media,
right, because it
was everywhere.
The media ran story
after story about what
was happening in Russia.
Second, even the International
Olympic Committee
had to get involved because,
pressured by LGBT activists,
they actually raised concerns
with the Russian government
to ensure the safety of
LGBT athletes and tourists
during the Sochi Winter Games.
There were people who questioned
whether Russian products should
be boycotted entirely.
And there were even some
not too far from here
who dumped vodka
that they thought
was made in Russia
into the harbor.
Russian LGBT activists
had to organize.
So imagine a country
as vast as Russia.
There are many
different organizations
working for LGBT rights.
There are many allies
working alongside of them.
And they had to form a
coalition and find unanimity
because suddenly they
had to answer questions
flooding in from around
the world about what
was good solidarity and
what would be hurtful.
Celebrities from Lady Gaga
to Madonna to Elton John
spoke out against the bill.
And you know that an issue
has been mainstreamed
when American Apparel start
selling t-shirts about it.
And we go from Russia to
India, hopefully with love.
In 2009 the New Delhi
High Court struck down
the country's sodomy law.
The sodomy law was a colonial
inheritance from the British.
And with it, the
New Delhi High Court
issued a verdict so stunningly
beautiful in its affirmation
of humanity and human rights
that it became a model
decision, studied
around the world.
The court found
that the sodomy law
was in violation of the
Indian constitution,
specifically the guarantees
of equality before the law,
prohibition from discrimination,
and the protection of life
and personal liberty.
So as you can imagine, LGBT
activists, LGBT people in India
rejoiced.
But the decision was
appealed to a higher court.
And in December 2013, the
Supreme Court of India
struck down the ruling.
And with its decision,
sodomy was again
criminalized in India.
Because of the influence of the
decision of the New Delhi High
Court, everyone was
watching and waiting
for years for this decision.
Indian activists working
through the coalition known
as Voices Against 377 called
for a day of solidarity.
And in less than a
week, on December 15,
vigils and protests were
held throughout the world.
Moving on from India to
Uganda, which I think
is probably the most
famous story of them all.
The issue of LGBTI
rights in Uganda
resurfaced one
Friday in December
when the Ugandan
parliament convened
an extraordinary session
to pass what was then
known as the
anti-homosexuality bill.
And two weeks ago,
Ugandan president Museveni
signed the bill
into law, never mind
that homosexuality was
already criminalized.
Have you guys been
hearing about Uganda?
Yes.
It's been hard not
to hear about it
because it's such
a serious issue.
And the reason why it's
such a serious issue
is because what's actually
written into the law itself.
So I'll just highlight
four points about the law.
The first is that
the new law calls
for life imprisonment for
so-called serial offenders.
So someone utterly
boring like me,
who goes home to my
partner every day
and tries to cook dinner
but sometimes just
succeeds in ordering
takeout, I would
be considered a serial offender.
And I would be liable
upon conviction
to life imprisonment.
The second point is that
activism for LGBT rights
is criminalizes, with conviction
of up to seven years in prison.
And it is written into
the law in a way that
is so broad that human rights
activists of all stripes
can be targeted.
So what you see is
that this law is also
being used to silence debate,
to silence public opinion,
to silence dissent.
A third issue in my
reading of the law
is that it effectively sentences
LGBT people to homelessness.
And this is because,
again, the law
is written so broadly
and punitively
that any landlord would
fear criminal conviction
for up to five years for
renting to someone suspected
of being LGBT.
And in that scenario, what I
think is also really important
is that the rule of
law doesn't really
matter because you
don't get charged.
You don't go before
a magistrate.
It's the mere
perception that you're
LGBT that makes you guilty.
And the fourth and final
point that really strikes me
about the Ugandan law
is that it effectively
requires Ugandan to
tell on Ugandan, parent
to tell on child, neighbor
to tell on neighbor,
in a complete erosion
of the social fabric,
or else face between five and
seven years in prison for,
quote, "aiding and
abetting homosexuality."
A law so far reaching
and so damning
is not good for anyone,
whatever your views are
on homosexuality
and transgenderism.
At the signing of the
bill, President Museveni
announced that
homosexuals-- and I'm
going to quote him here--
"should rehabilitate
themselves, and society
should assist them to do so,"
end quote, leaving little
doubt as to his intention
to reinforce his own political
career on the bodies of LGBT
Ugandans, human rights
defenders, and their allies.
But significantly,
the world noticed.
Within days, President
Obama said, and I quote,
"Enacting this legislation
will complicate
our valued relationship
with Uganda."
The governments of Norway
and the Netherlands,
both major donors
to Uganda, announced
that they would redirect
portions of their foreign aid
away from government
programs in Uganda.
And in a third
example, the World Bank
announced that it would delay
a $90 million loan to Uganda.
But I want to
underscore that when
we're talking about LGBT rights
in other people's countries,
we have to also think about LGBT
rights here in this country,
in the United States.
And things have
been looking pretty
good for LGBT people in the
US, and that's something
that we celebrate.
And I really celebrate
it standing here
in California, given all the
work that people have done here
to achieve the progress that
we all are now enjoying.
But I want to remind
everyone that it was just
last month that the Arizona
legislature passed a bill that
would've made it
legal for businesses
to refuse service to anyone
they perceived to be as LGBT.
And it took the governor's
veto to prevent this bill
from passing into law.
And so I think
it's not surprising
that the "Atlantic"
magazine, which
is a 125-year-old mainstream
journal that studies policy
and current events wrote an
article a month ago about how
Sochi became the gay Olympics.
I want to move on from
the kind of theory
of the law to the effect of
the law because, as we know,
it's one thing
travel on the books,
but it's quite another thing
to see how it's implemented
and what impact it has on
people's everyday lives.
So starting with Russia, LGBT
Russians and mainstream human
rights activists tell IGLHRC
that the anti-gay laws
are a test for a crackdown on
vulnerable groups across Russia
more broadly.
Today, they say, it
is the LGBT community,
but tomorrow it could be
immigrants and racial,
religious, or ethnic minorities.
They tell us that the
treatment of LGBT Russians
is a litmus test for a
broader right-wing momentum
around state power.
Putin's influence in the
Ukraine and deployment
of troops of late has
underscored their analysis.
And I just want to underscore
this is not about Russian
bashing because there has been
all too much of that lately.
And there's an ugly
history of Russia
bashing in the United States.
This is actually
about understanding
that there is always a
difference between society
and the government.
But I do want to say that
when the government sacrifices
one group, when the
government incites hatred,
there are consequences.
Neo-Nazis and
gangs of thugs have
rounded up those they suspect
of being LGBT in Russia,
shaved their heads to out
them, beaten them severely,
and then bragged
about these beatings
by posting videos online.
In the context in
India, I would say
that the movement is
getting back on its feet
after what can only be
described as a devastating blow.
Lawyers for 377 filed something
called a review petition that
amounts to an appeal,
but it was rejected.
And they are regrouping
and figuring out next steps
because, clearly, justice
through the courts
is going to be a
long time coming.
In the context of Uganda,
I'll cite maybe five examples
of what the effect has been.
Have you guys read about
the tabloid outings
that have happened?
Yeah.
So within days-- I
think it was actually
within less than 24 hours
of President Museveni
signing the bill into law,
the first tabloid published
an article.
"Top 200 Homos," it
declared on the front page,
literally sacrificing
people's safety and security
in the interest
of tabloid sales.
Since then, they've
run subsequent stories
and a second newspaper has
also published names, photos,
and descriptions
of people, making
them totally and
completely unsafe.
As a consequence,
LGBT people in Uganda
are terrified, and so are
human rights activists because
of the far-reaching
nature of this law.
Within days of the bill
being signed into law,
we heard of eight
suicide attempts.
And of course President Museveni
has gained a distraction
from other domestic
initiatives that
have come under
scrutiny for violating
international human
rights standards,
such as the public order
management bill, which
is basically an attack on
community-based organizations
and nonprofits, and the
anti-pornography law, which
in many ways is an
attack on women.
And in the process, he
won populace credibility.
He recently received
the endorsement
of a group of religious leaders
for a fifth term in office.
Five.
So I guess in
summary I would say
that whether or not
someone finds themselves
in the crosshairs
of one of these laws
directly, whether or not
a police officer stops
them, arrests
them, charges them,
they go before a court of
law, and they are eventually
convicted, these laws
have a criminalizing
effect on LGBT people.
They incite hatred
against vulnerable groups.
They make it hard to do HIV and
AIDS prevention and treatment.
They make it hard for people
to rent homes, get jobs, go
to school, feel like they are
valuable and have self-worth
and are entitled to be alive.
And these laws
incite mob justice.
They so thoroughly
demonize a group of people
that neighbor turns on neighbor.
Are you all really depressed?
Good.
You should be.
But that's not the full story.
I think that when we hear about
these kinds of initiatives
being codified
into law, we should
be freaked out, we
should be horrified,
and we should be angry,
especially when we're
standing in the Bay
Area and so many of us
have LGBT people in our
lives that matter to us.
And we care about human rights.
We know that this is wrong.
But I want to argue that
although this moment
and these examples
of legal inequality
are horrifically bad,
I believe that this
is a temporary dip in the
overall trajectory of equality
and justice for LGBT people.
And so I want to give
you some examples outside
of these countries so that
you can hear about what's
not really being
covered in the news.
In Nigeria, the same sex
marriage prohibition bill
was signed into law by President
Goodluck Jonathan in December.
And this was very bad.
And it is incredibly serious
for activists in Nigeria.
But the bill was
first introduced
in Nigerian parliament in 2006.
And they kept the bill at bay,
so they fought successfully
for years.
And that showed the
tenacity of a movement.
In Zambia, Paul Kasonkomona,
an outspoken HIV
and AIDS activist,
dared to say that stigma
around homosexuality
and transgenderism
fueled the AIDS crisis.
And he found himself
facing criminal charges.
And last month, when standing
before a court of law in Zambia
just outside of
Lusaka, he was forced
to answer the charges
that he had violated
public decency, public morality,
by making such statements.
He was acquitted.
He was acquitted by a local
court of law in Zambia.
And in Chile-- no one
ever talks about Chile
in the American press--
things are happening.
And I want to tell
you that they're
happening on a major scale.
The senate recently
passed a bill
that would recognize the
expressed gender of people,
regardless of
bodily modification.
And so transgender
people won a victory
in the Chilean senate
with a vote of 29 to zero
in their favor.
And last but not least, I think
we can talk a little bit more
about Uganda as a case study.
The bill was, much like the
version in Nigeria, first
introduced years ago.
It was introduced in
2009 after a group
of American evangelicals,
including the pastor known
as Scott Lively,
traveled to Uganda
and said it's not enough to
think homosexuality is a sin.
You have to criminalize those
that agitate for LGBT rights.
And so Ugandan activists
made public the role
of American
evangelical strategies
and money and
power and influence
in the introduction
of this bill into law.
And they called out these
tools used by Americans.
And they said,
actually, not only
is this most recent
version of foreign import,
but the original sodomy law is
also a British colonial legacy.
And what is Ugandan is tolerance
and community and compassion.
And to prove it, they even built
a coalition of human rights
organizations that now includes
approximately 35 organizations
of all political
stripes, including
academic institutions,
organizations working
for women's rights, for refugee
rights, for HIV and AIDS,
and even for the rule of law.
And so what I want
to argue to you
is that, yes, we're seeing
very severe and very dangerous
setbacks around the
world for LGBT rights.
But these setbacks
have in many instances
come as a result of people
asserting their rights.
So this is a backlash
against progress.
And what gives me hope is that
LGBT communities are actually
building coalitions with
mainstream human rights
organizations and
building alliances
that make social
change possible,
not just the legal kinds, but
the part where society actually
changes.
So I want to kind of
move into the summary
by talking about what
global solidarity is useful
and what's counterproductive.
I want to underscore that
while I am an optimist and so I
believe these setbacks
are temporary,
it does not make the dangers
faced by LGBT people,
people perceived as LGBT,
and people doing human rights
work in these countries
and other countries
around the world
any less vulnerable.
Make no mistake, it
is life threateningly
dangerous to be LGBT, to
engage in LGBT practices,
to talk about the right to human
sexuality or bodily autonomy,
or to speak out for human
rights in many countries
around the world today.
And so I think it is the
responsibility of those of us
who are not on the front
lines to be scrupulously
careful with how we
enact our solidarity.
And I'm going to give you four
examples of what not to do
and one extremely easy, very
specific, and utterly vital
example of what to do.
So first, the first don't.
Don't essentialize.
Don't think that all
Russians, Indians, or Ugandans
are homophobic or transphobic.
Perhaps this is obvious,
but you would be surprised
what you read in the
comments pages under articles
and what people have said to me.
Don't think that all people
in eastern Europe, south
Asia, or east
Africa are, either.
You know about these
laws because LGBT people,
their families, their friends,
their religious leaders,
their human rights colleagues
are standing alongside of them
and made these examples
international news.
And there is always
the difference
between a government
and its people.
The second thing I would
not recommend that you do
is play Noah's ark.
Don't fantasize about it either.
Don't think that all Russians,
Indians, or Ugandans want
to leave their country and/or
come to the United States.
Some do, and we
have an obligation
to make it easy for those people
who need asylum and refugee
status to get the services
and support that they need.
This should be obvious.
But it should also be
obvious that not all LGBT
people can ever leave home.
And there is no such
thing as an LGBT country.
So we have to invest our
efforts, our solidarity,
in making sure that
people can live
in their homes with
their families safely.
The third thing
is very important.
I know that Google employees
have a history of philanthropy.
So the third don't is
don't donate foolishly.
I'm speaking to you
seriously about this.
Don't donate money without
knowing where it's going.
There is currently a
website circulating--
I am intentionally not
naming this website--
but it claims to be fundraising
to get all LGBT people out
of their countries
in harm's way.
Please don't be naive.
The savior complex
does no one any good.
And the fourth and final point
that I would say is a don't is
don't think that cutting all
foreign assistance to countries
with sodomy laws or
countries that have a track
record of punishing and
targeting LGBT people
is a good thing.
If LGBTI people
become the reason
that foreign aid is
cut to a country,
there will be retaliation
against the same people
that you want to help.
And different movements have
different strategies about what
foreign assistance can
be cut and what cannot.
Some would say you
can cut components
of foreign assistance
going to governments.
Some would say you
can only cut that
which is designed to
go to the armed forces.
But you can't cut
programs that are designed
to support clean drinking water,
microenterprise, education,
maternal health, et cetera.
The language around
this is very important.
So if you find yourself with
access to people in authority,
don't ask them to cut aid.
Ask them to redirect aid.
Redirect aid away from those
that have supported, endorsed,
and campaigned for
laws that would incite
and institutionalize violence.
Ask them to invest
in communities
that want peaceful solutions
and social harmony.
And from there, I'll
conclude with the example
of the one and only thing
that you really should do.
It's the one thing to remember.
And it's just listen to local
LGBT activists and communities.
They are the experts
of their own situation,
as we are all the
experts of our own lives.
I think with that, I will
conclude and say thank you.
AUDIENCE: This is just
outrageous and awful
and we need to do
things about it.
And thank you for stepping up
and coming and talking to us.
I'm just trying
to think of things
that we can do with you
because we have different skill
sets that we bring.
So I don't know exactly where to
take that but kind of an offer
to brainstorm about that.
And things don't just happen.
People do things, as we know.
So I thought your point
about local activists
are going to be the ones who
change their own country,
similarly, local oppressors
are doing the work too.
And so being conscious
about who and kind
of attacking at
the roots of things
seems like a good strategy.
We have an office in
Kampala, with Googlers there.
We have many offices,
actually, across Africa
and in lot of
places where there's
a lot of rights work going on.
So maybe some of them are
teammates, I don't know.
So I don't have an exact thing,
but I guess sort of an ask
to Googlers here and
online, wherever you are,
or who might watch NBC,
if they have ideas,
I'm interested in figuring
out what we might do.
Pretty hard stuff.
JESSICA STERN: I think there's
a lot that Google could do.
And I'd probably want to
give it a little bit more
thought than off the cuff
because you're powerful
and you should use
that power well.
I think ensuring that
all of your office places
are safe, regardless of what
country people are working
for you in is of
the utmost priority.
I think that where Google
has access to government
and where you have conversations
with government officials,
carrying the principles
of nondiscrimination
is phenomenally
important and also making
an argument for business
and human rights.
When people are safe in
the workplace, when people
are safe as consumers,
business flourishes.
And I think there's a
way that an organization
like the International Gay and
Lesbian Human Rights Commission
can make that.
But it has a totally different
authority when it actually
comes from a
company saying that.
Just to kind of flag,
there are huge issues
around the safety and security
of LGBT people online going far
beyond these countries.
There are instances
of internet entrapment
that happen all the time.
And online communication,
online community building,
is so fundamental to LGBT
communities around the world.
I actually think it's
one of the reasons
that we've seen so much
progress in the past five years
because people can
find each other.
And when you can
find each other,
you can start doing this
movement-based work that's
so important.
But then the question
is, how do you
help make sure people are
consuming internet services
safely so that they
can find each other?
And we know of many
governments that
have set up entrapment
strategies that have resulted
in a range of horrors
for LGBT people.
I don't know what Google does
around safety and security,
but I think that would be
really important to talk about.
AUDIENCE: Hello, I'm Ervin.
JESSICA STERN: Hi, Ervin.
Nice to meet you.
AUDIENCE: I'm very
involved in this
as I actually have three
friends on the ground in Uganda,
all of whom are running
for their life right now.
You said to work
with local activists,
so my first question is,
how do we identify them?
There's a lot of
deception out there
and a lot of groups
of dubious value.
You said you don't
want to name names.
I'm going to ask
you to name names.
Who is actually effective and
useful, especially in Uganda,
but other places as well?
JESSICA STERN: Well,
Uganda's a great example
where people actually
have come together.
And there's something called
the Civil Society Coalition.
It's the group that I was
talking about earlier.
It has been an
incredibly useful place
to turn to for strategies
about navigating the new law.
It's actually the work of
the Civil Society Coalition
of Uganda that's spearheading
a legal challenge to the law
that they're filing
tomorrow if all goes well.
And I would be more
than happy to put you
in touch with the Safety
and Security Committee
of the Civil Society Coalition.
There's also a number of really
extraordinary organizations
working for LGBT
rights in Uganda, too.
Just to give a brief
shout out-- and if people
are watching online, there
are many more of you.
But SMUG, Sexual
Minorities of Uganda,
is a coalition of many
LGBT organizations.
And FARUG, Freedom
and Roam Uganda,
focuses on lesbians and
trans* people in Uganda.
And I'd be happy to talk
with you more later.
So you can Google them.
And The Civil Society
Coalition of Uganda
is trying to get actually a very
sophisticated 20-point strategy
for standing in solidarity with
people in Uganda right now,
out far and wide.
And it is currently
available in a Google Drive,
actually, that you can access
through the IGLHRC website
if you go to the
Uganda country page.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about foreign aid, right.
You made a point-- and I
think it was a good one--
that countries sort of offering
foreign aid to countries
like Uganda have to be
careful about whether
or not to sort of cut
off giving foreign aid.
But there are also churches.
There are churches that
give their own private aid.
To what extent do you
think, I don't know,
American evangelicals,
for example,
are providing aid to
countries like Uganda?
And do you think that that had
any influence on the Ugandan
president's decision to
sign this law, right?
I mean, perhaps
he doesn't really
worry about not receiving
US government aid because he
can get aid from
private churches.
JESSICA STERN: It's very
hard to track money.
So there have been
scholars and activists
who've been trying to
track the money that
has flown from right-wing
American evangelical churches
into Uganda.
And some have been more
successful than others.
I would direct you to the work
of the Rev. Dr. Kapya Kaoma
as one person who's
done work on this.
And another person
is Jeff Sharlet.
I think American evangelicals
have exported a range of tools
to countries like Uganda.
We see Scott Lively popping
up in eastern Europe.
It's not only Russia that has
these anti-gay propaganda laws.
But there were
similar initiatives
introduced in the parliaments
of Lithuania, Moldova,
among others.
And some of this has
to do with money,
but it also has to do
with access to power,
access to American
politicians, access
to American companies and
less tangible enticements.
In the question that
Wendy posed about
whether American evangelicals
influenced President Museveni's
decision to sign
the bill into law,
I think that President
Museveni-- all of these
are hard questions.
I think President Museveni has
mounted a defensive strategy,
if you will,
claiming nationalism
as a reason for signing
this bill into law.
And that's very dangerous
because nationalism
isn't actually
about Ugandans when
the bill he signed
into law violates
Uganda's own constitution.
Uganda recently discovered
really deep and rich oil
reserves, and they're
scheduled to begin production
in either 2015 or 2018.
So there is some feeling
that perhaps Uganda
will be less dependent
on foreign assistance
than in the past.
There's also some
feeling that there's
another geopolitical
axis through which Uganda
and other countries
like it can receive
foreign assistance,
those that are supporting
the criminalization
of homosexual acts.
So I hope that
answers your question.
AUDIENCE: I will ask another.
I've seen different
sources for the actual text
of the final bill
that was passed.
It would be nice to know what
the authority version is.
And I'm not sure
I'm accessing it.
But as I understand it, the--
JESSICA STERN: Sorry,
is this in Uganda?
AUDIENCE: Yes, Uganda, sorry.
I know, I'm focused there.
JESSICA STERN: It's OK.
AUDIENCE: The bare text of it
criminalizes conduct and not
status.
So the question is, do
we believe it matters?
Meaning, is there enough
rule of law left there?
Now, of course there's rampant
vigilantism which is grievous.
But insofar as people
actually arrested and accused,
do we even believe there's
any rule of law left that they
would bother to prove actual
behavior as opposed to status
or not care?
Does that makes sense?
JESSICA STERN: Yeah, it does.
Yes, the rule of law exists,
but so does mob justice.
Both things are true.
I do want to say
that there's reason
to have hopes from
the Ugandan courts.
In 2010, a tabloid that
existed at the time
did publish the names,
photos, and home addresses
of a number of LGBT
activists, putting them
in direct harm's way.
One of those individuals who
was targeted in the paper
was David Kato, an activist who
may be familiar to some of you
because he was
subsequently murdered.
And the high court
of Kampala actually
heard a case on this
particular issue.
And it was the case
of Kasha Jacqueline
versus "Rolling Stone."
And I'm happy to report that
the Ugandan court actually
ruled in the activist and
LGBT community's favor
in a really excellent
decision that recognizes
the right to privacy,
among other things.
So I think there is
hope through the courts.
And you have to believe
in the role of law
and work for it because
that's what we have.
AUDIENCE: It seems that both
the Russian and the Ugandan law
criminalizes support of
LGBT right rights as well.
JESSICA STERN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So how does
that stifle organizations
that try to argue
this in the court?
Are they still able to do that?
JESSICA STERN:
[INAUDIBLE], you're
asking an excellent question.
How do you say that a
law is unconstitutional
when it's against the law
to say that the law is
unconstitutional?
I mean, that's
basically what this is.
I think that the laws
that have recently
been introduced and passed
into law in Uganda and Nigeria
have very little to do with
criminalizing homosexuality
again because homosexuality
was already against the law
under the penal code.
I think it's really
an attack on activism.
And I don't think there's any
easy answer to your question.
And I would just underscore
that groups doing work
around LGBT rights
in these countries
are wondering how they
can continue to exist.
They are literally fighting
for their own survival.
And they're fighting
courageously and strategically.
But put yourself
in their situation.
Everywhere I look around
here, I see the word "Google"
because that's where you work.
So your office is branded.
Now what if "Google" meant LGBT?
Everything about this
space would suddenly
become a liability.
So I think these are
very difficult questions,
and we just have to keep
monitoring the situation
and hope that the
laws are thrown out.
ELLEN SPERTUS: Thank you
for coming, all of you,
but especially Jessica.
JESSICA STERN: Thank you guys.